so by now we're all familiar with the
problem of delegation so let's say that
you have a time T computation M on X and
you'd like to learn the output but you
may be a resource bonding machine such
as a SmartWatch and you don't want to
run this computation yourself so what
you'd like to do is to have a more
powerful machine such as the cloud
perform the computation and send back
the answer and we'd like to verify the
answer so we asked the prover to send
back a proof pie and ideally we'd verify
in time much less than it would take to
perform the computation ourselves so
this brings us to the central question
Ken verifying really be faster than
computing namely can we design such a
protocol where we can delegate
computations where verification is
faster than computing and we have the
soundness guarantee so we know that if
we allow interaction between the prover
and the verifier then the answer is yes
at least for some classes in complexity
we do have interactive protocols where
we can verify faster than it would take
to compute ourselves but the transcript
of an interaction is not really what
we'd like to have as a proof for
instance a transcript is not
transferable the soundness of of these
protocols relies on the prover answering
honestly generated messages from the
verifier and so this means that you
can't take the transcript from one
interaction give it to another person to
verify and have them trust that the
verifiers messages in this transcript
were honestly generated so when you take
a transcript and give it to someone else
he has no reason to trust this as a
proof for the computation
so ideally what we like is for the
roofer to be able to just write down a
statement M on x equals y and approve Pi
and maybe he would write this down in a
book or on a blockchain on the internet
and anyone should be able to come and
verify this proof at anytime with no
interaction and so formally this is
what's known as a publicly verifiable
and non interactive argument and it's
what we're going to construct today so
of course we have the completeness
condition which says that we can compute
a convincing proof for any true
statement and now first soundness we
know that in any proof system there
should exist proofs that verify for
false computations so we should only be
considering soundness against bounded
provers and to do this we'll work in the
crs model where you can think of the
hard the computational hard problem as
being in the CRS so now the CRS will be
generated or ahead of time independent
of the computation and it can be reused
again for many different computations
over and over and our soundness
guarantee says that no computation bound
approver can output a false statement
and a convincing proof with
non-negligible probability over the CRS
so there's been a lot of prior work on
publicly verifiable arguments namely we
have constructions based on the
following assumptions and we consider
all of these assumptions to be
relatively strong for instance we know
that going from the random Oracle month
going from security and the random
Oracle model to an actual and
instantiation with an explicit hash
function is non-trivial and in knowledge
assumptions we don't have a reduction to
an underlying hard problem and I just
want to mention that in the construction
provided by PR based on multi linear
Maps the problem there is that we don't
have any candidate constructions of
multilinear maps that suffice for their
construction so it remained an open
problem to construct a publicly
verifiable argument from falsifiable
assumptions and we're going to see how
we solve this problem today but I want
you to keep in mind that we do know
lower bounds namely we have the negative
result of Gentry Analects which says
that there is not an argument for NP
from falsifiable assumptions even if we
forget about public verifiability so lot
with a black box proof of security and
adapter sound yes yes there's some
quantifiers yes
and earlier today you heard the talk by
Alex which talked about this concurrent
work where they do make progress on this
problem they construct an argument that
supports boundary def circuit
computations and they rely on what's
called optimal security of fhe which not
which says that naively the the best the
best attack to the end these fhe schemes
is to naively guess a secret key and
this is still a relatively strong
assumption and ideally we'd like to
construct an argument that supports a
wider class of computations not just
bounded def circuits
so that's where our result comes in so
we construct a publicly verifiable non
interactive argument for any polynomial
time computation based on the following
assumption on by linear groups so the
assumption says that if you have a group
with a bilinear map if you sample a
generator G for logarithmic alpha if
you're given this three by alpha matrix
of group elements for a random at for a
random s it's hard to distinguish
between the case where T is an
independent random element and where T
is the power s to the two alpha plus 1
so first as a sanity check note that
even with a bilinear map this this power
as to the two alpha plus 1 should be
indistinguishable from a random group
element and in intuitively you can you
can think of this assumption as just
saying that given these certain small
powers of s and the exponent look these
larger powers of s should be
indistinguishable from random group
elements so our assumption holds in the
in the generic group model and although
it's new to our knowledge it's similar
in spirit to a lot of violent group
assumptions made previously in
cryptography first line and second line
is that if they are excited erring then
I would go all the way up to right yeah
so yeah so that's why we started with
two alpha plus 1
so just a second the question about the
serum so these are big differences
between adaptive sounds and other
adaptive summers in this context so
first of all together that we've samisen
ii know so yeah we get adaptive
soundness and essentially what we do is
like in the CRS you you could think of
the simpler problem of constructing the
schemes for a fixed computation but then
we replaced that computation with the
universal Turing machine so then we do
get adapted saunas constructed from
weaker solution
again this is always for me all right
you just break it down so same gene
between T but then I wasn't given this
matrix as between human element to this
other the same
yeah so yeah so this matrix isn't random
like with with the bilinear map you can
definitely see like GT x GS will give
you this element so it is a structured
matrix but there's no so like it does
holding in the generic group model so
like with the trivial kind of addition
and addition in the exponent and one and
one multiplication we know that you
can't distinguish we don't know that it
does get violated yeah but we'll but it
suffices to just assume it for
logarithmic alpha for our construction
so we try to make the weaker assumption
at least in terms of the parameter alpha
so this concerts only do we reduce it to
something horse more like you know
the GG to the X e to the Y I did they
expire we can't be even if I force
constant constants not enough for us we
need actually like cat oh I got it but I
don't know how to think that one has
been made before for yeah so we don't
know how to reduce it to like do the age
for instance but at least for you know
alpha one I believe I've seen that
before we we do need the logarithmic
alpha for us I actually won't focus too
much like at the end if there's time or
interest I can talk a little bit about
our actual encrypt so so this so this
assumption comes in the semantic
security of our encryption scheme which
is based on by linear groups and at the
end I can talk a bit about that
construction and where this matrix comes
in
but yeah so in an overview of our result
end this talk is we we obtained this
result in two steps first we construct a
publicly verifiable argument for P with
the long CRS so this means that if you
give me a time computation T then I can
generate a CRS which has length poly T
in in time poly T and then you can use
this urs for computations up to time T
and note that even just this argument
scheme on its own is useful because the
CRS here is independent of the
computations and it's reusable and in
the publicly verifiable setting and so
in step two what we'll do is we'll
bootstrap this argument scheme to obtain
a scheme with a sure CRS and this just
means that we're going we're going to
apply recursive proof composition
so those of you that are familiar with
bootstrapping and recursive proof
composition may think this should just
follow from prior work for instance
though the work of BCC T does show how
to bootstrap using argument schemes but
it our step 2 doesn't actually just
follow from prior work because these
prior works relied on using arguments
for NP that were actually knowledge
extractors or snarks and we know that we
can't have an argument for NP at least
in the non adoptive or at least in the
adaptive setting based on a falsifiable
assumption and our focus is to construct
an argument based on falsifiable
assumptions where we're trying to remove
the strong assumptions so we need
something new here and so how do we
bootstrap it'll be useful for us to
think of this notion of a quasi argument
for NP so this is a protocol that's
defined for any NP computation but it's
not clear what kind of soundness
guarantee it provides in particular it's
only going to give us what we call local
extract ability and so this means that
if we have a prove that gives us
convincing proofs we can't trust that
the computation actually is correct but
at least for deterministic computations
if we have a convincing prove err
then we can trust that the computation
is correct so what I mean by this is if
you have a quasi argument for NP with
with local extract ability then you can
use this to delegate deterministic
computations and it has what you would
want as the traditional notion of
soundness and this follows from from the
previous works of colores in Rockland
so a more accurate overview of what we
do is we construct a quasi argument in
step one this gives us an argument for
deterministic computations and then in
step 2 we bootstrap using both of these
elements so we used a quasi argument to
bootstrap the argument for P and then
that's how we get our argument for P but
with a shorter CRS and it is very
important that we're bootstrapping a
deterministic computation as we'll see
so this is kind of a an overview of what
our work does but in this talk I want
you to try to just take away two points
the first is how do we achieve public
verifiability what we do is we're going
to use a special encryption scheme and
this really is based on the previous
works of beneath and Roth gloom and in
the second step the in this
bootstrapping step the the main the main
takeaway is that this local extract
ability property suffice is to bootstrap
arguments for deterministic computations
before bootstrapping relied on having
full extract ability or snarks
so let's start with step one so this is
I'm going to kind of give a high-level
overview of what are our protocol looks
like and this is base and this protocol
is is based on the previous works of
care are in PR so let's say the prover
wants to prove a computation M on X he
performs the computation writes down the
tableau and in the CRS we're going to
put encrypted queries where each query
points to a location in the tableau and
then the prover is going to homomorphic
evaluate the answer for each query and
send this back as the proof so this is
just the the BMW heuristic and now the
verifier is going to just check that
these that these answers for a small
part of the computation are locally
correct so what this means is that these
answers are status by any local
constraints for that part of the
computation
and the question is how do you do this
in a publicly verifiable way because
everything here is encrypted the queries
are encrypted the answers are encrypted
and the verifier doesn't have any secret
keys or anything so the answer is you
use a special encryption scheme and this
encryption scheme is it was introduced
by PR and is called an encryption with a
weak zero test and they construct a
protocol very similar to the one that
ours is based on and they construct a
protocol where the verifier can just use
the zero test to check for local
correctness and they also construct a
zero testable encryption based on multi
linear maps as I mentioned we don't have
candidate constructions for these Maps
so what our work does is we construct a
zero testable encryption from bilinear
groups and we change their protocol a
bit to make it possible to still verify
local correctness using our particular
encryption
so zero testable encryption is just an
encryption with its algorithm zero test
which takes a ciphertext and that and it
this algorithm recognizes whether the
ciphertext encrypt zero so I said it's a
zero testable encryption scheme so
shouldn't the zero test contradict
semantic security and the answer is it
doesn't have to if zero test only
recognizes very trivial encryptions of
zero for instance if we think about the
function f being the identically zero
function and the ciphertext that you get
by evaluating this function f on a fresh
ciphertext C then this ciphertext will
pass the zero test and note that this
ciphertext would pass the zero test
regardless of what's encrypted in C so
we don't have to contradict semantic
security
so now the question is how do you use
the zero test non-trivial e because if
this is all that the zero test does and
the verifier is just performing zero
tests then can't the prover always win
like the prover could always just
evaluate the identically zero function
on any query and this ciphertext should
pass the zero test right and the answer
is what we'll do is we'll try to use the
the zero test in in a slightly smarter
way so you can think of this function f
on queries and answers is checking the
local correctness of these answers and
you can also and and we can break down
this function f into two parts a
verifier part and approver part and so
this prove apart all he does is he
should just be evaluating the answers or
the bits in those look in the locations
specified by Q in the tableau if you
remember that and then this verifier
just finishes the computation checking
the local correctness of Q and a and
this function in the honest case is 0
for any query
so the verifier has these encrypted
queries in the CRS and encrypted answers
he finishes his computation and then he
puts this ciphertext in into the zero
test
and that's all that he uses to check for
local correctness and we reconstruct a
George Hospital encryption from bilinear
groups and I can for those that are
interested I can talk about how we go
from multilinear to bilinear and where
that assumption comes in
so that was the first point I wanted you
to take away that to get public
verifiability we can by using a special
encryption scheme and now the second
point that I'll try to convey is that
this this local extract ability that we
have in the protocol that we just saw
suffice is to bootstrap
so yeah zero test works
yeah so that notion was introduced by
them and yeah this is this is just I
think this is so I just wanted to convey
the idea of your testimony yeah yeah our
our work is just constructing this
encryption but based on by linear groups
and reducing to that assumption maybe
that's what you mentioned that's what I
wanted to say is because one yeah yeah
so yeah so also in previous in in the
previous work with with the multi linear
map on they didn't have the long CRS
problem like the the reason why we have
a long CRS is you can kind of think of
in them in a multi linear map you can
perform many multiplications right and
in our setting with the bilinear map you
can only perform one multiplication so
we help you a bit we'll do like kind of
all the multiplications you may need to
do to homomorphic evaluate on a function
on cue and so our ciphertext for Q will
be big so that's why are our CRS is long
I don't think I'll have too much time to
talk about bootstrapping but I wanted to
just convey that there's this idea of
local extract ability which is different
from the extract ability that you get
from snarks basically what you get is
you you can extract any small part of
the tableau and get answers that look
correct just for that small part and
these answers satisfy some consistency
constraints that are formerly known as
no signaling and previous works show
that local extract ability has been has
been useful in particular you can take a
quasi argument with a local extractor
with or with local extract ability and
it's automatically a scheme that sound
for certain subclasses in NP and what we
do is we show that this local extract
ability is also useful and sufficient
for bootstrapping
and
I think so so so the punchline here
essentially is that if you use a local
extractor remember you can read any
small part of the computation and the
important point is that when you read a
small part of the computation you can
you you can be sure that the computation
in in a few steps proceeds from some
configuration C 0 to some configuration
C 1 and the important part is that
because this computation is is
deterministic namely there's only one
correct so it so if you start from C 0
there's only one correct C 1 and only
one correct C 2 and so on you know that
when you read this part if you get
something that looks locally correct
then the C 1 is the correct
configuration at this time step and then
we'll use this local extractor and move
it up to read another part of the
computation and we know that the by no
signaling the configuration we read here
is consistent so it's the same same
correct C 1 and then again we'll get a
proof that verifies for this part of the
computation so then we know that C 2 is
the correct configuration and that's the
argument at a very rough high level to
show why having this local extract
ability property will allow us to
bootstrap but only for deterministic
computations
so and in summary our result is
constructing a publicly verifiable non
interactive argument for deterministic
computations based on that by linear
group assumption I showed earlier and we
do this by first constructing an
argument with the long CRS and we make
this this protocol publicly verifiable
by using a very special encryption
scheme with a weak zero test and the and
and the work here was in constructing
that encryption scheme from bilinear
groups and making the protocol and
designing the protocol in such a way
that using just by linear maps works or
it's efficient and then in step two we
we bootstrap on our hour-long CRS
protocol to obtain an argument with a
short CRS and the takeaway here is that
this local extract ability property is
is actually sufficient to bootstrap when
the underlying computation is
deterministic that full report is online
thank you
[Applause]
many thoughts about knowledge we've made
it this far to make it even further and
maybe construct achieve the same result
but with a given from reference uh yes
yeah so I should mention right on yeah
so right right yeah I should mention it
yes yeah so our encryptions are
structured so like we have we we we do
though we do some pre-processing there
so you can recognize a cipher a valid
ciphertext from just random group
elements I'm not sure about uniform
reference string
yeah I haven't thought about very much
because the I think the problem there
would
I'm not sure how to make use of the of a
uniform reference under the Optima
harness assumptions in the previous talk
so basically have two sets of
construction based on future mayor and
are they still it is the theme that we
para if you want and if you look at just
like protocols for P or even for NC then
these last two talks are two different
approaches of getting the results from
concrete assumptions assumptions um but
this direction will definitely not
result in a public CRS and and then
maybe you should start from the future
mere result to try to extend them to
push them to all the people in this folk
science here but improve to get rid of
the optimal artist a with this
more questions
[Applause]